This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个由 I-Heart 制作的播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将剖析心理坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。即“2”这个数字。在《回顾历史》(The Look Back at it) 播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984年对我也意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克兰蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾历史》。嘿，各位，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方说真的都不安全，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一层铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这个能力，就代表你必须这么做。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的教训》。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what
播客。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷g，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《深陷情网》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we discuss all things, the psychology of your 20s. Today, we're going to talk about a phenomenon that I think has only recently gotten a label. It's very own term in the last couple of decades or so, and is now a phrase that I think has become part about everyday dating vocabulary, and that is the ick, getting the ick. You know, I often think that we think of the ick as just like very humorous thing, something that's not that serious, we joke about it, it's an everyday kind of conversational phrase, but there's also a significant number of
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听我们新一期的节目，我们将在这里讨论与“你二十岁的心理学”相关的一切。今天，我们要讨论一种现象，我认为它直到最近几十年左右才被贴上标签、拥有了自己的专属名词，而现在这个词已经成为日常约会词汇的一部分，那就是“厌烦感”（the ick），产生“厌烦感”。你知道，我经常觉得，我们把“厌烦感”看作是一件非常搞笑的事情，一件没那么严肃的事，我们拿它开玩笑，它是日常对话中的一种常用词汇，但同时也有大量的心理学理论和观点可以解释为什么我们会产生这种厌烦感，我们会对特定的、几乎是微不足道的事情感到厌烦，特别是当我们审视关于吸引力、过度警觉、拒绝敏感性、情感回避甚至是我们的直觉等概念时。我认为这比 TikTok 潮流所呈现的要深得多，它深深植根于我们作为人类和社交动物的心理之中。所以今天我们要把这一切都剖析清楚。在这期节目中。因此，“厌烦感”指的是，由于某种行为、事件或怪癖，你突然对曾经吸引过你的人完全失去了浪漫或性趣，这种行为或事件突然让你对这个人彻底倒胃口，最终，你知道的，让你觉得必须彻底结束这段关系，觉得你再也不能和这个人在一起了。这位名叫古皮特·辛格的关系顾问兼心理治疗师。心理治疗师说，“厌烦感”与仅仅怀疑自己是否想和某人在一起有点不同。这种“厌烦感”在很大程度上是一种排斥感。这是一种非常强烈的直觉反应，针对的是这个人的言行举止、行为方式或者完全是别的什么。而这种直觉反应让我们觉得自己再也不能和这个人在一起了，哪怕我们根本没有任何正当的
psychological theories and ideas that can explain why we get the ick, we feel the ick towards specific, almost small things, particularly when we examine concepts around attraction and hypervigilance, rejection, sensitivity, emotional avoidance, and even our intuition. It is a lot deeper than the TikTok trend, I think, makes it seem, and it goes really deep into our psychology as humans and social creatures. So we're going to break it all down today. on this episode. So the ick refers to very quickly losing romantic or sexual interest in someone
理由去觉得他们的所作所为毫无魅力。我会说，有时候这种“厌烦感”是完全情有可原的，比如当某种行为在某种程度上揭示了他们整体的个性和价值观时，那是一种更深层次的倒胃口。这比最初那个行为在表面上看起来的样子意味着更多，我想到的事情比如虐待动物，或者看到某人在喝醉时非常生气，或者卫生习惯不好。那是一种超级合理的“厌烦感”。但我认为这个概念的前提与我们看到的那些相对无害的行为有很大关系，这意味着它们通常是无害的、超级随机的。我们无法预测它们。它们并不是某种更大或更重要事情的象征。这只是一种非常小众的、几乎是自发产生的、
you were once attracted to because of some kind of behaviour or event or quirk that suddenly turns you completely off this individual and ultimately, you know, makes you feel like you need to abandon the relationship entirely, like that you cannot be with this person any longer. This relationship counsellor and also a psychotheraper. therapist called Guppyit Singh says the ick is kind of different to just doubting whether you want to be with someone. The ick is very much a repulsion. It's a very strong gut reaction either to the mannerisms of the person or the way they behave or something else entirely. And that gut reaction makes us feel like we can no longer be with that person, even if we have no justified
让我们无法解释的倒胃口，哪怕我们理性地认为它是正当的。我们无法忽视那种立刻觉得不再被这个人吸引、甚至对他们感到排斥的感觉。这种感觉就在那里，它注视着我们，它要求我们采取行动，哪怕某人所做的一切只是，你知道的，背着双肩包到处跑，或者穿着我们不喜欢或在第一次约会时不愿分享食物的鞋子，我们就会立刻感到排斥。我有这样一个理论，它分为三个截然不同的类别，当然，这些是我根据大量的 TikTok 观看经验和与朋友的对话总结出来的。这并不是什么科学的分类模型，而是一个更多基于观察和轶事的模型。我们有我们的行为型“厌烦感”。
reason for finding what they did unattractive. I would say sometimes the ick is completely warranted, like when the action kind of reveals something more about their overall personality and values, that is a deeper turnoff. That means kind of more than what the initial action may look like at the surface level, things that I think of are like beaming to animals or seeing someone really angry when they're drunk or having poor hygiene. That is a super justified ick. But I think the premise of this concept has a lot more to do with the kinds of behaviors we see as relatively innocuous, meaning they are quite often harmless and super random. We can't predict them. They're not a symbol for something bigger or more significant. It's just this really niche, almost spontaneous
这些都是一些事情，比如追着一个乒乓球跑。这似乎真的是一个非常普遍的现象。或者娃娃音、某种走路的姿势、吃饭声音很吵、连发三条信息、低级笑话，这些都与某人的行事风格和行为有关。然后我们有我们的身体型“厌烦感”。这通常是关于某人的外表或他们选择穿的衣服。比如在海滩上戴护目镜，我承认我自己就很喜欢这样。我想看看水里有什么。所以如果这也是一种“厌烦感”，我懂，但我也会这么做。或者穿某种类型的衣服，比如紧身牛仔裤、某种发型、像我们之前讨论过的不良卫生习惯，
turn off that we can't explain, even if we rationalize that it's justified. We cannot ignore the feeling of just immediately no longer finding this person attractive, even being repulsed by them. The feeling is there, it's staring at us, it's demanding action, even if all someone did was, you know, run around with a backpack on or wear shoes that we didn't like or didn't want to share food on the first date, were immediately repulsed. I have this theory that it's come in three distinctive categories, which I have obviously formulated based on copious amounts of TikTok viewing and conversations with friends. This isn't like a scientific categorization model, but one that is more, I think, observational and anecdotal. We have our behavioral icks.
关于某人外貌、感知、外界版本的自己的事情。最后是我们的情感型“厌烦感”，我认为这是我们最应该给予关注的“厌烦感”，比如虚荣、不停地照镜子、盛气凌人、大发雷霆。拜托，你已经是成年人了。请成熟地处理我们的情绪。求求你了，谢谢。
These are things like chasing a ping pong ball. That seems to be a really common one actually. Or baby voice, a certain way of walking, being a noisy eater, triple texting, crude jokes, things to do with how someone chooses to act and behave. Then we have our physical ick. This is normally about someone's physical appearance or the things that they choose to wear. So wearing goggles at the beach, which I will admit I'm very much guilty of. I want to see what's in the water. So if that's an ick, I get it, but I do that as well. Or wearing certain types of clothes like skinny jeans, a certain hairstyle, poor hygiene like we spoke about before,
或者，你知道的，对服务员态度不好。我认为这是一个非常重要的指标，它指向一种更深层的态度和价值观，而“厌烦感”只是在向我们发出警告。还有一些只是有点超出了所有的界限。比如某人把某个特定的词读错了。我甚至看过这样一个视频，有人说，某人的名字让我感到厌烦，字面意思上的名字，因为它太无聊了。我认为关于“厌烦感”，有一点是普通人并不总是能理解的。但“厌烦感”的决定性元素之一是，相对于我们的潜意识偏好，它是高度个人化和主观的。有时候，这些偏好甚至是我们自己都不理解的。甚至在我们看到关于
things about someone's like physical appearance, perception, outside version of themselves. And then finally we have our emotional icks, which I think are the icks that we should pay the most attention to, things like vanity, constantly looking in the mirror, being overbearing, having, you know, a tantrum. Like, come on, you are an adult. Let's process our emotions. Productively, please. And thank you.
某人的行为、行事方式或他们在做什么之前，我们甚至都没有意识到。这只会让我们觉得对他们深深地失去吸引力。不是因为它说明了他们是谁的更深层含义，而是出于除此之外的其他一些原因。我想快速说一下，因为我觉得这太迷人了，“厌烦感”也可以根据我们在两性关系中被告知要对浪漫伴侣有什么样的期望而产生性别差异，这取决于我们的性别，取决于我们被影响去觉得什么有吸引力，什么没有。如果你是一个女性，在约会环境中，“厌烦感”可能更多地与我们对男性的礼貌、情感界限、倒胃口的事物或特定行为的期望有关。但男性的“厌烦感”似乎更多与身体有关，这可能与以下发现有关：
Or, you know, not being nice to wait stuff. That's like a really big indicator of, I think, a deeper attitude and value set that the ick is just warning us about. And then there are some that just kind of extend beyond all bounds. Like someone who says a particular word wrong. I even saw this one video where someone was like, someone's name gives me the ick, their literal name, because it's too boring. I think the thing about icks is that they don't always make sense to the average person. But one of the defining elements of the ick is that it is highly personal and subjective relative to our subconscious preferences. Sometimes these are preferences that we don't even understand. We're not even aware of until we see something about
女性在恋爱中优先考虑情感和契合度，而男性，尤其是年轻男性，则认为吸引力和外表是更重要的因素。现在，我找不到关于这方面的任何研究。所以实际上，如果你正在寻找一个有趣的研究课题，这可能会是一个非常有趣的课题。但我认为这只是其中一种解释。我们的约会偏好受到社会和性别期望的影响，这就是为什么男性和女性会有所不同。这也是为什么我们的“厌烦感”——也就是我们立刻发现关于某人的、我不想说令人作呕，因为这是一个强烈的词，但确实是非常没有吸引力的东西——将基于我们认为自己所处的性别或我们的生理性别。那么，我们的“厌烦感”是合理的吗？我们真的应该那么
someone's behavior or how they conduct themselves or what they're doing. That just makes us feel deeply unattracted to them. Not because it says anything deeper about who they are, but for some other reasons beyond that. I want to quickly say, because I found this so fascinating, Ix can also be gendered based on what we're told to expect from our romantic partners depending on our gender, what we're influenced to find attractive and not. If you are a woman, icks may be more relative to manners or emotional boundaries or turnoffs or particular behaviours that we expect from men in a dating setting. But male icks seem to be more physical, which could potentially be related to those findings
挑剔吗？还是说我们甚至在刻意决定什么对某人有吸引力、什么没有？其实我并不认为我们在这件事上有选择的余地，对吧？我认为这些“厌烦感”是非常不由自主且非常自发的，而且有一些理论——我们稍后会讨论——表明它实际上来自于我们心灵的一个非常无意识的部分，这个部分正试图向我们发出关于某事的警告，或者对我们与另一个人之间的长期契合度有着更强的直觉感知，但我也认为“厌烦感”这个概念有点吓到我了，因为它究竟说明了吸引力和总体上爱的本质是什么？你知道的，其中一个前提，即关于产生“厌烦感”的潜在信念之一是，它几乎可以在任何阶段发生。
that women prioritise feeling and compatibility in a relationship, whilst men, particularly younger men find attractiveness and appearance a more significant factor. Now, there have not been any studies on this that I could find. So actually, if you're looking for a fun research topic, that might be a really interesting one. But I think that is just one explanation. Our dating preferences are influenced by societal and gendered expectations, which is why they differ for men and women. And that's why also our icks, what we like immediately find kind of, I don't want to say revolting because that's a strong word, but really unappealing about someone is going to be based on the gender that we see ourselves as or our sex. So are our icks justified? Should we really be that
这就好像按了一下开关，我们曾经觉得有吸引力的东西突然变得无法忍受。所以它似乎表明，我们对某人的吸引力并非我们想象的那么无条件，我们可能会像坠入爱河一样容易地不再爱一个人，这完全取决于某人的怪癖和他们特定的行为。而且，你知道的，按照这个逻辑，这正是让我感到恐惧的事情。你可能已经结婚20年了，突然有一天你的伴侣决定穿错类型的袜子，或者打嗝的方式有点奇怪，然后你就对他们产生了厌烦感。你产生了厌烦感。实际上，这与一个被称为“致命吸引力理论”的更深层概念有关，它与“厌烦感”略有不同，但这是由黛安·费尔姆利 (Diane Felmley) 教授提出的一种假说，她认为
particular or are we even deliberately making a decision about what we do and do not find attractive about someone? I don't actually think that we have a choice in the matter, right? I think that these icks are like quite involuntary and quite spontaneous and there are theories that we're going to talk about later that suggests that it actually comes from a very unconscious part of our mind that is trying to warn us of something or has a greater intuitive sense of the long-term compatibility between us and someone else but I also think that the concept of an it kind of scares me because what does it really say about the nature of attraction and kind of love in general? You know one of the premises, the underlying beliefs about getting the ick, is that it can kind of occur at any stage.
我们最初觉得某人有吸引力的特质，比如他们的幽默感、自发性、认真负责，有时正是这些特质最终导致了关系的破裂。当我们开始以一种新的眼光看待这些曾经的正面特质时，我们最喜欢自己或别人身上的东西，往往也是我们最不喜欢自己或别人身上的东西。我认为这更多地与契合度有关，因为本质上我认为我们都从自己经历“厌烦感”的个人经验中知道，这种感觉通常是留给那些早期的日子的，对吧？那些初次约会的日子，那些前几个月，我们在不同的背景下看待某人，也许是在考验他们，看看
It's this flip of a switch whereby the things we once found attractive are suddenly unbearable. So it kind of seems to suggest that our attraction to someone is not as unconditional as we think, that we can fall out of love just as easily as we can fall in love based on someone's quirks and their particular behaviours. And, you know, by that logic, and this is the thing that terrifies me. You could be married for 20 years and suddenly your partner decides to wear like the wrong kind of socks or kind of burps a little bit weird and you get the ick. You get the ick. Actually it relates to this deeper idea known as fatal attraction theory, which is somewhat different to the ick but this hypothesis proposed by Professor Diane Felmley, she believes that the
我们是否合拍，而在那个阶段，当我们正在约会但又不是真正确立关系时，对于任何事情可能不会顺利的迹象，我们都处于高度警觉状态，对那些让我们对某人倒胃口的事物高度警觉。我认为这在我们首次对某人产生浪漫依恋时充当了一种奇怪的分水岭，我们不得不提出这样一个问题：我们是否能接受这个人并不完美？我们能否忽视他们所做的一些日常小事，这些事可能会有点烦人，或者我们不会用同样的方式去做？我想每个处于长期伴侣关系或婚姻中的人都会告诉你，你不可能去爱
things we initially find attractive about someone, like their humor, their spontaneity, their conscientiousness, those are sometimes the things that actually cause the relationship to break down in the end. When we begin to see these once positive traits in a new light, the things that we love the most about ourselves or about someone else are also the things that we dislike about ourselves or someone else the most. I think that has more to do with compatibility because inherently I think we all know from our personal experience with the ick that it's kind of reserved for those early days right those early first dates those first months where we are seeing someone in a different context perhaps testing them out seeing
你伴侣身上的绝对一切。总会有那么一些时候，他们会惹恼你或者做出一些让人沮丧的事情，但这与“厌烦感”是不一样的。它与那种字面意思上让你对一个人感到排斥、或者让你内心感到局促不安的瞬间厌恶感是不同的。这就是“厌烦感”和“交易破裂点”（deal breaker）之间的区别，我认为“deal breaker”更符合我们的价值观和需求。“厌烦感”其实只是一种心理测试。比如，我是否愿意对一个人身上的这些小事保持宽容？还是说这对我来说实在是太多了？所以也许，一些治疗师也提供了这样的解释，
if we fit and during that stage when we are dating but not dating we're pretty hypervigilant to any signs that things might not work out hypervigilant to the same to the things that turn us off from someone. I think it's serve this kind of weird fork in the road when we first become kind of romantically attached to someone and we have to kind of ask the question, are we okay with this person not being perfect? Can we overlook the small little everyday things they do that might be a little bit annoying or that we wouldn't do the same way? I think everyone in a long-term partnership or marriage will tell you that you cannot love. absolutely everything about your partner. There will be times that they annoy you or do things
我们将小事情认定为一种退出的借口。也许它们只是一层无意识的烟雾弹，掩盖了我们想要离开或不想和这个人在一起的更深层原因，无论是因为他们身上的某些特质，还是我们自己的原因，比如情感上的冷漠。我们没有选择去面对这样一个事实：也许我们还没有准备好让事情进一步发展，或者我们对建立联系是封闭的，或者担心对方可能会先对我们失去兴趣，而是在我们变得过于投入之前，或者在看到可能让我们感到受伤或被拒绝的
that are frustrating, but it's not the same as the ick. It's not the same as that instant disgust that literally makes you feel repulsed by a person or leave you internally cringing. And that's what is the difference between an ick and a deal breaker, which I think a deal breaker is more aligned to our values and our needs. The ick is really just like a mental test. Like, am I willing to tolerate these small things about a person? Or is it just too much for me? So maybe, and some therapists do offer this explanation,
更大潜在问题之前，我们对某些随意的事情扣动了扳机。这只是看待问题的一种方式。也许这也是你内心深处有真实原因在告诉你快跑。这种“厌烦感”与更宏大的事情有关，比如正如我们所说的一个 deal breaker，一个红线。但你知道，这些“厌烦感”也某种程度上，就像我刚才说的，是一颗烟雾弹，对吧？有时它确实是大脑对我们说的一种方式：哦，在内心深处，我知道我不喜欢这个人，在内心深处我可能不想和他们在一起。所以我的大脑会寻找他们行为中的一些小细节，从而给我一个离开的理由。这会在某种程度上向我展示我的潜意识已经知道的事情，那就是这里没有未来。而且你知道的，这些“厌烦感”，尽管我们真的把它们集中在浪漫伴侣身上，
we identify small things as an out. Maybe they are just an unconscious smoke screen for a bigger reason we want to leave or that we don't want to be with this person, either because of something about them or about ourselves, like emotional unavailability. Instead of deciding to confront the fact that maybe we are not ready to take things further or that we are closed off to a connection or worried about the other person maybe being turned off by us first, we pull the trigger on something arbitrary before having to get to invested or maybe see the bigger potential problems in our relationship that could leave us
它们可能不仅限于那些我们认为有性吸引力或与之有亲密联系的人，它们还可以延伸到我们的朋友、同事、熟人，甚至是陌生人，你知道的，尽管我们从这些“厌烦感”中恢复过来的速度可能更快，但如果你看到有人在街上绊倒了，而你觉得有点尴尬，那可能就是一种“厌烦感”的体现，虽然强度较小但仍然显而易见。那种本能，那种尴尬源于几个地方。首先，有些人理论化地认为，这其实只是将心比心的尴尬，“厌烦感”是通过批判对我们自身羞耻感的一种投射。当我们看到那些失误，那些我们觉得尴尬的事情时，
feeling hurt or rejected. That's just one way of looking at it. Maybe it's also a real reason in your gut is telling you to run. This ick is related to something bigger, a deal breaker, as we said, a red flag. But you know, these icks are also kind of, like I said, a smokescreen, right? Like, sometimes it really is a way for our brain to be like, oh, deep down, I know I don't like this person, deep down I probably don't want to be with them. So my brain is going to find something small about their behavior that's going to give me a reason to leave. That's going to kind of show me what my unconscious thoughts already know, which is that there isn't a future here. And you know, these icks, although we've really been focusing on them in reference to romantic partners,
我们会把自己想象成处于那种处境中。而且，你知道的，这也许是同理心和自我意识的结合，但我们感受到了他们所感受到的，并且我们感到尴尬。并且承认另一个人在那一刻可能是脆弱的，这种感觉非常强烈。而这种脆弱感，如果我们还没有准备好去面对，或者如果这个人只是一个随机的陌生人，是非常具有冲击力的。因此，它给了我们这种非常尴尬、不舒服的感觉，就像是，
they might not just be reserved for the people we deem as sexually attractive or who we are intimately connected to in that way, they can also extend to our friends, to our co-workers, to our acquaintances, even strangers, you know, although our recovery from these icks is probably quicker, but if you see someone trip on the street and you kind of cringe, that might be a version of the ick, you know, less intense but still palpable. That instinct, that cringe comes from a few places. Firstly, some theorize that it's really just secondhand embarrassment, The ick is a projection of our own shame through criticism. When we see those slip-ups, those things that we find awkward,
哦，我要把视线从那上面移开。这让我感觉有点怪怪的。还有一些理论认为，“厌烦感”实际上可能是我们的直觉在发挥作用。也许它源于某些先前的不良联想，或者它是一种自我防卫策略。但它也可以是刻意的。这是一种通过给自己制造“厌烦感”来摆脱某人的刻意方式，通过想象对方处于一个我们知道自己会觉得没有吸引力的场景中。所以，这其中很大一部分都建立在一些非常微妙的社会心理学基础之上，在短暂的休息之后，我们将会探讨所有这些潜在的解释以及更多内容，还有我们的“厌烦感”是如何在伤害我们的。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中。在这个奇怪的现代世界中，我将剖析心理坚韧、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
we imagine ourselves in that position. And, you know, maybe it's a combination of empathy and self-awareness, but we feel what they're feeling and we feel embarrassed. And acknowledging that that other person is probably like vulnerable in that moment is kind of really intense. And that vulnerability, if we're not ready for it yet, or if this person is just a random stranger, is quite confronting. And so it gives us this like really awkward, uncomfortable feeling that's like,
来抛开那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。即“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
oh, I'm going to look away from that. That kind of makes me feel a bit weird. There's also some theories that the ick is actually, perhaps our intuition working in our favor. Maybe it emerges from some previous negative association or it's a self-defense strategy. But it also can be deliberate. It's a deliberate way to kind of get a.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾历史》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克兰蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，1984年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但是，对，对，对。
over someone, by giving ourselves the ick, by imagining that person in a scenario that we know we're going to find unappealing. So a lot of that is based in some really nuanced social psychology, and we're going to explore all of those potential explanations and more, alongside how our ics may be harming us after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
但为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上桌面了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回顾历史》。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验。与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, yeah.
特里普·方丹、瑞恩·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深深地陷入追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的比赛。
But just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right. now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的。压力，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field. conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我凯尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难成长的教训》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《艰难成长的教训》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出明显的矛盾。她在撒谎。
Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
这引发了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different. tensions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. She's in her story.
马里科帕县传来消息，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Love Trapped 播客。所以“厌烦感”是真实的。我们知道它存在。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
我想我们都曾感受过。但它的实际目的是什么？它从何而来？为什么会发生？所以就像我说的，有几种理论，有些是科学的，有些则不那么科学，都与这些非常具体的问题有关。让我们仔细看看其中的一些。我想回到我们之前简略讨论过的事情上来。一种可能是，我们对非常微小的、有时是微不足道的事情感到的“厌烦感”，实际上是一种自我防御机制或策略，旨在保护我们免受关系破裂、对承诺的恐惧、对亲密关系的恐惧或拒绝敏感性的伤害。最后一点在这里非常重要。如果我们不断寻找他人的缺点，我们花在审视自己缺点上的时间就会减少。
Greg Alesspian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news
但我们也能捕捉到他们可能拒绝我们的任何机会。这就是我们对他们的行为保持高度警觉的来源，也是对我们自己保持高度警觉的来源，我们想要将其投射到别人身上，以不那么强烈地感受到那种焦虑。所以人类，我们是社会性动物，我必须在每三集里说一次，因为这是如此真实。我们天生就极度渴望寻求亲近、安全感、接纳和爱。但如果我们感到受到威胁或对峙，出于自我保护的驱动力，我们可能会寻找方法与这个人保持距离。我们没有去承认那种感觉、那种恐惧，而是在别人身上寻找某些东西，因此我们产生了“厌烦感”，以在那些脆弱的时刻达到，你知道的，某种自我保护的目的。
at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So the ick is real. We know it exists.
也许我们也在寻找一个理由来结束与某人的关系，因为我们实际上对他们没有任何感觉，但我们又不想承认这一点，或者我们因为拒绝某人而感到内疚，也许是因为他们身上并没有什么特别不对的地方。他们可能是一个完全很好的人。所以我们的大脑会进行一种叫做“事后理性化”的操作，去寻找一个合适的理由来支持我们其实已经在内心做出的决定，但我们还没有为它找到一个真正的正当理由。因为我们没有一个合法的理由，我们便满足于某种其他的解释。我们创造了一种“厌烦感”。你知道的，就像有一天，我突然注意到他的腿太毛了，或者他在海滩上穿运动鞋，无论是什么，
I think we've all felt it. But what is the actual purpose? Where does it come from? Why does it occur? So like I said, there's a few theories, some scientific, some less so, to do with these very questions. So let's have a closer look at some of them. So I want to return to something that we spoke about kind of briefly before. One possibility is that the ick that we feel towards really small, sometimes negligible things is actually a self-defensive mechanism or strategy to protect us against relationship failure or fear of commitment, fear of intimacy or rejection sensitivity. The last one is really important here. If we constantly look for the flaws of others, we spend less time examining our own flaws.
这其实并不是你恋爱关系中的一个巨大因素，但它是一个你可以用来为某个更深层的决定辩护的理由，即你其实不想和那个人在一起。所以再一次，这不是有意识的，也不是刻意的，而是以某种隐蔽的方式发生的。此外，这种“厌烦感”可能是一种自我创造的投射，或者是你关系中尚未浮出水面、但我们已经能隐约感觉到的其他不满意情绪的代理。这与“习得性心理联结”的概念有关。有时我们觉得所谓的排斥、瞬间尴尬、对某人感到惊讶地没有吸引力的东西，全都源于先前的不良联结。
But we also get to pick up on any opportunities that they might have to reject. us. So that's where our hypervigilance towards their actions comes from, hypervigilance towards ourselves, that we want to project onto others to not feel that anxiety as intensely. So humans, we are social creatures, I must say that, every third episode because it is so true. And we are innately really driven to seek proximity and security, acceptance and love. But if we feel threatened or confronted, we might look for ways to distance ourselves from this person out of a drive for self-protection. Instead of acknowledging that feeling, that fear, we search for something in someone else and therefore we get the ick to, you know, kind of serve the purpose of self-preservation
人类是通过重复的联结来学习的。这基本上意味着，当我们经历。一种刺激并引发某种特定的情感反应时，我们便开始相信这种刺激将永远引发那种情感反应。例如，如果你每次吃某种食物都觉得恶心，你就会停止吃这种食物，因为你的大脑已经了解到这种食物等于生病。或者你甚至在看到它时就会感到，你知道的，厌恶，而不需要去品尝它或把它放进嘴里。这些联结通常与经典条件反射有关。它们告诉我们由于先前的负面经历而应该避免哪些事情，
in those vulnerable moments. Maybe we are also looking for a reason to end things with someone because we just actually don't feel anything for them, but we don't want to admit that or we feel bad for rejecting someone because maybe there is nothing in particular that's wrong with them. They might be a perfectly fine person. So our brains engage in something called post-rationalization, going in search for an appropriate reason for a decision that we've already kind of inherently made, but we don't really have a justification for it yet. So because we don't have a legitimate reason, we settle on some other explanation. We create an ick. You know, like one day, I kind of notice that his legs were too hairy, or he wore sneakers to the beach, or whatever it is,
而不需要我们再次去经历它们。但有时我们的大脑会做出错误的联结。比如说，你的前任总是取消计划、忽视你，或者不给你提供关爱和关注。那种情感体验显然会引发一些非常糟糕的感觉。而这些感觉会留在我们身边。但假设你的这个前任，他们还穿着，你知道的，某种特定鞋子。他们穿着，我不知道，添柏岚（Timberland）、Vans 或是阿迪达斯。在这种情况下，我们的大脑做出了错误的联结，以至于我们开始将鞋子与负面经历联系起来。所以也许你和某人进行了第一次约会。他们穿着添柏岚。他们穿着 Vans。立刻产生厌烦感。立刻产生厌烦感。而这种“厌烦感”正是因为先前的这种
that is not actually a huge factor in your relationship, but it is a reason that you can use to justify maybe a deeper decision that you don't really want to be with that person. So once again, not conscious, not deliberate, but occurring in some kind of hidden way. Also, that ick might be a self-created projection or proxy for some other dissatisfaction in your relationship that hasn't yet come to the surface, but we can already kind of sense. This links to the idea of a learned mental connection. Sometimes the things we find quote unquote repulsive, immediately awkward, surprisingly unattractive about someone, all stems from a previous negative association.
负面联结。所以我们的大脑正在激活这种厌恶的通路，以某种方式警告我们远离，认为这个刺激、这个物品在警告我们注意过去类似的负面情感体验，也就是我们和那个糟糕的前任在一起时的体验。说实话，那个添柏岚的例子，实际上出于这个原因，它是我个人的一种“厌烦感”。它让我想起了一个我曾经谈过恋爱的人。我会退缩，并且立刻觉得那没有吸引力，因为它是一个提醒。
Humans learn by repeated association. So that basically means that when we experience. one stimulus and it elicits a certain emotional response, we start to believe that that stimulus will always elicit that emotional response. For example, if every time you eat a certain food, you feel sick, you will stop eating that food because your brain has learned that this food equals illness. Or you will feel, you know, even discussed when you see it without having to taste it or put it in your own mouth. These associations, they're often related to classical conditioning. They tell us what things to avoid because of a previous negative experience without
提醒我想起我真的不喜欢那个人的所有事情。这与他们的鞋子没有任何关系。这与很多事情有关，你知道的，比那多得多。它要深得多。但我的大脑却在说：好吧，这东西是其他事情的线索，所以让我们避开这个东西。也许这在某种程度上说明了产生“厌烦感”的体验也可以被解释为直觉，这就是为什么当我们对正在交往的某人产生“厌烦感”时，
needing us to experience them again. But sometimes our brain can make the incorrect association. Say, for example, your ex would always cancel plans and ignore you or didn't provide you with affection or attention. That emotional experience is obviously going to elicit some really terrible feelings. And those feelings stay with us. But say this X of yours, they also wore, you know, a particular kind of shoe. They wore, I don't know, timbulins or vans or Adidas. Our brain in that situation makes the wrong association, such that we begin to associate the shoes with the negative experience. And so maybe you go on a first date with someone. They're wearing the timbulins. They're wearing the vans. Immediate ick. Immediate ick. And that ick is because of this previous
我们总是忍不住注意到它并采取行动，它似乎是凭空出现的。当你理解直觉时，它是一个极其强大的工具。我们有时感到的那种直觉，那种直觉本能是经过科学证实的，它是我们所有感官的投射，是大脑利用过去的经验，结合内部信号和来自环境的线索来做出决定的结果。也许这是我们原本不会做出的决定。我们的大脑会注意到一些我们可能尚未有意识地意识到的事情。所以它可能会在这个人身上看到一些我们的意识并不了解的东西。
negative association. So our brain is activating this pathway of disgust to kind of warn us to stay away, thinking that the stimulus, this item is warning us of a similar emotional experience in our past, the one that we had with the bad X. That Timberland example, I'm not going to lie, it's actually a personal ick for me for that very reason. It makes me think of someone that I used to be in a relationship with. And I squirm and I immediately find that unattractive because it's a reminder.
我不知道这是否特别正确，尤其是当它基于某种随意的事情时，比如，你知道的，只是做了一些有点奇怪的举动。如果你想要的是这些，我不认为这是性格或我们与某人未来可能性的强有力指标。但这是一种思想流派，认为“厌烦感”来自于某种未知的、无法识别的直觉，但是，你知道的，它可能是正确的，也可能不正确，但它正试图通过某种奇怪的联结，或者也许通过某种
of all the things that I really didn't like about that person. And it didn't have anything to do with their shoes. It had something to do with a lot, you know, a lot more than that. It was a lot deeper. But my brain has been like, all right, this thing is a clue for something else. And so let's avoid this thing. Maybe that kind of goes to show how the experience of getting the ick could also be interpreted as intuition, which is why when we get the ick towards someone we're seeing,
捕捉到你尚未真正有意识地注意到的东西的途径，以某种奇怪的方式保护你，即使它稍微有些偏差。但有些人也只是超级挑剔，甚至对其他人会原谅、会忽略的事情指指点点。如果你不知为何经常经历“厌烦感”，那可能是因为你自己在充满批判和判断的环境中长大。你妈妈总是对别人的穿着评头论足，或者对其他人不会注意到的小事评头论足，并断定这些小事意味着更多。但现在你也会注意到这些事情。通过模仿父母的行为，你已经学会了拥有那种雷达，并对我们所有人都有的那些微小的尴尬怪癖保持高度警惕。这也可能是因为
we can't help but notice it and act on it, it kind of comes out of nowhere. Your intuition is an incredibly powerful tool when you understand it. That gut feeling we sometimes get, that gut instinct is a scientifically proven projection of all of our senses and our brain making use of past experiences, along with internal signals and cues from our environment to make a decision. maybe a decision that we wouldn't have made otherwise. Our brain picks up on things that we maybe don't consciously realize as of yet. So it might see something in this person that our conscious mind does not.
你有一种不安全感，但你没有去承认那种感觉，而是把这种感觉转移到别人身上来分散自己的注意力。这其中很大一部分来自于一些真正奇怪的内部关系，这些关系影响了我们维持对某人的长期吸引力的能力。你知道的，我觉得非常有趣的是，有些人甚至经历了一位作家所说的“选择性厌烦”，选择故意去想某人处于不尊严的处境中，以此来放下他们。我的一位朋友前几天实际上发了一个关于这个的视频，大意是：如果你想放下他，只需想象他向服务员要更多，你知道的，要更多的水，但他们却忽略了他。或者想象他被自己的鞋带绊倒。在这种情况下，
I don't know whether that is particularly correct or not, especially when it's based on something arbitrary, like, you know, just doing something a little bit odd. I don't think that's a really strong indicator of character or our potential for a future with someone if that's what you want. But that is one school of thought that the ick comes from some unknown. unidentifiable gut instinct, but, you know, it may or may not be correct, but it's trying to protect you in some weird way through some weird association or maybe through some kind of
你是在故意在脑海中创造出你知道会让你倒胃口的场景。这几乎是没有回头路的，但如果你知道自己不该被某人吸引，这倒是一种绝妙的情感小技巧。比如如果他们本身在情感上不可及，或者他们给你发送混合信号，或者那是你的前任，而你想找到一个快速的解决方案，把那种爱和吸引力变成厌恶。我实际上看到了其他一些例子，我觉得太搞笑了。它们让我哈哈大笑。
pick up of something that you haven't really noticed consciously yet, even if it's slightly misgiven. But some people are also just super picky or even judgmental towards things that other people would forgive, that they would ignore. If you chronically experience, the ick for some reason, it may be because you, yourself, were raised in an environment of criticism and judgment. Your mom was always commenting on what people were wearing or small things that no one else would notice determining that they meant something more. But now you also notice those things. You have learned from modeling your parents' behavior to have that kind of radar and hypervigilance to the small awkward quirks that all of us have. It may also be because
捕捉到一些你尚未真正有意识注意到的东西，即使它稍微有些偏差。但有些人也只是超级挑剔，甚至对其他人会原谅、会忽视的事情带有批判性。如果你经常莫名其妙地感到“下头”，那可能是因为你自己在充满批判和判断的环境中长大。你妈妈总是对人们穿的衣服或别人根本注意不到的小事评头论足，并认定这些小事意味着更深的东西。但现在你也注意到了这些事情。通过模仿父母的行为，你已经学会了对我们所有人都有的那些小而尴尬的怪癖保持那种雷达般的敏感和高度警惕。这也可能是因为
you have a sense of inadequacy, but instead of acknowledging that, you're displacing that feeling onto someone else to distract yourself. A lot of this comes from some really strange internal relationships that impact our ability to sustain a long-term attraction to someone. You know, what I find really interesting is that some people even undergo what this one author calls the elective ickiness, choosing to deliberately think of someone in an undignified situation to get over them. One of my friends actually posted a video about this the other day being like, if you want to get over him, just imagine him asking a waiter for more, you know, for more water, but they ignore him. Or like imagine him tripping over his shoelaces. In that situation,
你有一种无力感，但你没有承认这一点，而是将这种感觉转移到别人身上来分散自己的注意力。这很大程度上源于一些非常奇怪的内在关系，它们影响了我们维持对某人的长期吸引力的能力。你知道，我觉得非常有趣的是，有些人甚至经历了一位作家所说的“选择性下头”，选择故意去想某人处于不体面的处境中以彻底放下他们。我的一位朋友前几天实际上发了一段关于这个的视频，大意是：如果你想放下他，只需想象他向服务员要更多的水，你知道的，要更多水，但服务员却无视他。或者想象他被自己的鞋带绊倒。在那种情况下，
you are deliberately creating scenarios in your head that you know will turn you off. There's kind of no coming back from that, but it's kind of a brilliant emotional hack if you know you shouldn't be attracted to someone. Like if they themselves are emotionally unavailable or they're giving you mixed signals or it's your ex and you really want to find a quick solution to turn that love and that attraction into disgust. I saw some other examples actually that I thought were so funny. They made me laugh.
你是在脑海中故意制造你知道会让你倒胃口的场景。这种情况下基本上就再也回不去了，但如果你明知自己不该被某人吸引，这倒算是一种绝妙的情感捷径。比如如果他们本身情感上不可得，或者他们给你发出矛盾的信号，或者那是你的前任，而你真的想找到一个快速的办法把那种爱和吸引力变成厌恶。实际上我看到了其他一些例子，我觉得太搞笑了。它们让我笑出声来。
but one of them was like imagine him eating spaghetti and he gets like red bits all around his mouth or imagine him trying to pat a dog but he, you know, the second he reaches for the dog, it like walks away. Like that's secondhand embarrassment. That's secondhand cringe. That is the ick. You know, and in those situations we discussed where it's appropriate where you probably don't want to be attracted to this person anymore because it would create a negative outcome for you in the long term, you should totally leverage the ick. You should fuel that disgust to put up a necessary wall between yourself and that person. But if you are someone who experiences the chronic ick and cannot overcome it with every person you meet, even if they are a walking green flag,
但其中一个人就说，想象一下他吃意大利面时，嘴边沾满了红色的酱汁，或者想象他试图去摸一只狗，但你知道，他刚一伸手去摸那只狗，狗就走开了。这就是代入性尴尬。这就是代入性社死。这就是“下头”。你知道的，在我们讨论的那些合适的情况下——你可能不想再被这个人吸引了，因为从长远来看，这会对你产生负面影响——你完全应该利用这种“下头”的感觉。你应该利用这种反感，在自己和这个人之间建立起必要的防线。但是，如果你是一个经常感到“下头”，而且对见到的每个人都无法克服这种感觉的人，哪怕他们浑身都是优点，
I think that that's indicating something deeper, more internal, more personal, that is going on in those situations. Or maybe you're just in a dating rut, you know, I've got one friend, God bless her, but it's almost like clockwork. She goes on three dates with someone and she finds a reason to end it. And it's always something that most of us would see as pretty minor. But like I said, before, your icks are personal. Your icks are subjective. And they, you know, emerge not just from your preferences, but your relationship pattern.
我认为这表明了一些更深层次、更内在、更个人的东西，这些东西正在这些情况下发生。或者也许你只是陷入了约会死胡同，你知道的，我有一个朋友，上帝保佑她，但这几乎就像时钟一样规律。她和某人约会三次，就会找到一个结束关系的理由。而这总是一些我们大多数人认为相当微不足道的事情。但就像我之前说的，你的“下头”点是私人的。你的“下头”点是主观的。它们不仅源于你的偏好，还源于你的恋爱模式。
Your willingness to accept emotional vulnerability. Your willingness to realize that someone isn't perfect and you have to be okay with that. it no doubt can be really harmful when we constantly find something wrong with everyone and we listen to our ics as if they are objective truth. Because in those moments we're really unable to ever meet someone at a deeper level because we're allowing ourselves to be distracted by something that's probably just super arbitrary and super innocuous and not really relevant to anything about the relationship on a deeper level. So in those moments, here is what you need to ask yourself, is this thing I'm seeing that I don't like actually a big deal. Is it a deal breaker? Is it a red flag? Or is it maybe just my mind making an inaccurate association? Or is it perpetuating my emotional unavailability by giving me an unexplainable reason to not have to go further with this person.
你对接受情感脆弱性的意愿。你愿意去意识到某人并非完美，而你必须接受这一点。毫无疑问，当我们不断在每个人身上挑毛病，并把我们的“下头”感当作客观真理时，这真的会非常有害。因为在那些时刻，我们实际上无法在更深层次上真正了解某人，因为我们允许自己被一些可能极其随心所欲、极其无害、且与这段关系的更深层次没有任何真正关联的事情所分散注意力。所以在那些时刻，你需要问自己的是：我看到的这个我不喜欢的东西，其实真的是一件大事吗？这是一个原则问题吗？这是一个红线吗？还是说这只是我的大脑产生的不准确联想？或者它通过给我一个说不清道不明的理由，让我不必和这个人继续深入发展，从而延续了我在情感上的疏离？
Examine the ick. Why does that make you feel repulsed? Or why does it make you cringe at the other person? And is that actually justified? You know, the ick is not a death sentence and I want that to be super clear for my people who are worried they'll never recover from this chronic pattern of ickiness. Literally my first date with my now boyfriend and I hope he doesn't mind me saying this. he like hadn't made any concrete plans on the day and I almost didn't go. I was like,
审视这种“下头”的感觉。为什么这会让你感到排斥？或者为什么它会让你对对方感到尴尬？这真的有正当理由吗？你知道，这种“下头”并不是死刑判决，我希望对于那些担心自己永远无法摆脱这种长期“下头”模式的人来说，这一点要非常明确。实际上，我和我现在的男朋友的第一次约会——我希望他不介意我说这个——他那天没有做任何具体的计划，我差点就没去。我在想，
this is icky. I'm getting the ick. I don't know if we can recover from this. And now, you know, we're super in love and great and it's just part of the story. It's a funny little side quest. No one is ever going to be perfect. That's, I think, the core element of this conversation. No one is going to be perfect. And if that's what you're searching for, I think you might be disappointed. and that's not to encourage you to settle or anything like that, but to accept that people have small quirks. You know, those fashion choices that you might not agree with, wearing goggles at the beach, God forbid.
这太让人下头了。我开始觉得下头了。我不知道我们还能不能回到正轨。而现在，你知道的，我们非常相爱，一切都很好，这只是我们故事的一部分。这是一个有趣的小支线任务。没有人永远是完美的。我认为这是这场对话的核心要素。没有人会是完美的。如果你在寻找的就是这个，我想你可能会失望。这并不是鼓励你将就或者做类似的事情，而是去接受人们都有一些小怪癖。你知道，那些你可能不太认同的时尚选择，在海滩上戴着护目镜，上帝保佑。
It's kind of all part of the package. So searching for perfection is kind of an impossible task. It's a fruitless outcome. You're never going to find someone who isn't occasionally going to do something where you're a bit like, oh, that's a bit embarrassing because humans are embarrassing. I'm embarrassing, you're embarrassing. We all do things that perhaps make us feel cringe and make us feel awkward and make us feel weird. And we would hope that someone else doesn't see this and immediately think that it's some kind of broader judgment of our character.
这其实都是整体的一部分。所以寻找完美可以说是一项不可能的任务。这是一个没有结果的结局。你永远不会找到一个偶尔不会做一些让你觉得“哦，这有点尴尬”的事情的人，因为人类本来就是尴尬的。我很尴尬，你也很尴尬。我们所有人都会做一些事情，也许会让我们感到局促、尴尬和奇怪。而我们希望别人看到这些时，不会立即认为这是对我们品格更广泛的某种评判。
Treat the ick, I guess, like a relational junction, a relational challenge, a fork in the road. You can turn left and you can keep looking for that elusive, perfect person who is going to complete you. maybe this thing is a deal breaker. So you really don't want to be attracted to them anymore. Maybe this is a good thing. Or you can accept that real intimacy involves accepting someone for who they are, as they will hopefully do for you. True love kind of defies the ick.
我想，把这种“下头”的感觉当作一个关系的交汇点，一个关系上的挑战，一个十字路口。你可以向左转，继续寻找那个虚无缥缈、能让你圆满的完美之人；也许这件事真的是个雷区，所以你真的不想再被他们吸引了。也许这件是好事。或者你可以接受真正的亲密关系包括接受真实的对方，正如他们也会希望对你做的那样。真爱在某种程度上是可以战胜“下头”的。
Like we said before, it's kind of this point in your relationship. And I think it's an important point where if you are to experience the ick, it makes you decide, like, is this something I can overlook? Or is it like immediate disgust, immediate like vomit in my mouth, embarrassment? I do not want to be with this person anymore. Please don't touch me. You kind of have a choice as like, is that what this really is or is it, you know, my brain trying to tell me something else. I think that's especially the case when the Ix are quite arbitrary and small and can be overlooked. This was a really fun episode. I hope you enjoyed this brief psychological for a explanation of the
就像我们之前说的，这可以说是你恋爱过程中的这样一个节点。我认为这是一个重要的节点：如果你体验到了“下头”，它会让你做出决定，比如，这是我可以忽视的事情吗？还是说这是一种立刻的厌恶、立刻像想把吃的东西吐出来的尴尬？我再也不想和这个人在一起了。请不要碰我。你其实面临着一个选择，这真的是这么回事，还是说，你知道，这是我的大脑在试图告诉我别的事情。我认为当那些“下头”的点相当随意、微不足道且可以被忽视时，情况尤其如此。这是一期非常有趣的节目。我希望你喜欢这段对“下头”世界短暂的心理学解释，
world of the ick. Honestly, if you have experienced an ick, can you please DM me? I want to know your weirdest icks. No judgment. Just curiosity, please and thank you. I think it's such an interesting concept that we can be with someone and we're like, yes, they are amazing, they're so attractive, I want a future with them. And then they just do this one thing and suddenly that like tap of attraction and intimacy is like turned off. Like I think I understand it more now that we think about it from the intuition perspective or the defense mechanism perspective. And if you're someone who has never experienced the ick, I wonder if that's more associated with like a secure attachment style. That would be really fascinating to look into because I think especially with people who are avoidant, that would be a huge relationship.
老实说，如果你经历过“下头”，你能私信我吗？我想知道你经历过最奇怪的“下头”点。不作评价。纯粹好奇，求求了，谢谢。我认为这是一个非常有趣的 مفهوم：我们可以和一个人在一起，我们觉得，是的，他们太棒了，他们太有吸引力了，我想和他们有未来。然后他们只是做了这么一件事，突然之间，那种吸引力和亲密感的阀门就被关掉了。我觉得如果我们从直觉的角度或防御机制的角度来思考它，我现在更能理解它了。如果你是一个从未体验过“下头”的人，我想这是否更多地与某种安全型的依恋风格有关？研究这个会非常迷人，因为我认为特别是对于那些逃避型的人来说，这会是一个巨大的恋爱……
You know, people who are avoidant obviously stray away and push away emotional intimacy. And maybe that's why they experience the ick more because like we said, it is a proxy excuse to not have to get closer to that person. And I'm just rambling here. I think that would be such an interesting theory to look into. But I really do hope that you enjoyed this episode. I freaking loved it. It was kind of fun, you know? Like, I think it's one of those things where so often there is so much hidden psychology
你知道，逃避型的人显然会避开并推开情感上的亲密。也许这就是为什么他们更容易体验到“下头”，因为正如我们所说，这是一个不用去靠近那个人的替代借口。我在这里只是随便说说。我认为研究这样一个有趣的理论会非常棒。但我真的希望你喜欢这一期节目。我超级喜欢。这挺有趣的，你知道吗？就像，我认为这正是那种情况之一，很多时候，在那些看起来超级正常、就像我们日常生活词汇中极其随意的部分的背后，隐藏着如此多的心理学原理，
behind the things that just seem like super normal and just like a super casual part of our everyday vocabulary. And then when you examine it a bit further, there is like this whole secret underground of explanation. So thank you so much for listening. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to give us a follow. Follow along so you get notified when I post new episodes. I just did all of my episode planning for November and December and also January. And let me say, there are some good episodes coming out that I am beyond excited about.
而当你再进一步仔细研究时，就会发现这样一个充满秘密的地下解释世界。非常感谢你的收听。一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时给我们点个关注。关注我们，这样当我有新节目发布时你就能收到通知。我刚刚完成了11月、12月以及1月的所有节目规划。我想说的是，接下来会有一些非常棒的节目推出，我对此兴奋不已。
So make sure that you're following us. Give us a five-star review if you would like and share this episode with someone who needs to hear it. If you have an episode suggestion or if you have a contrary. opinion or you want to share your thoughts, please feel free to DM me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. We would love to have you over there to share in this journey and you can see behind the scenes content and video content as well. So once again, thank you for listening. I think I've said that about three times, but it was great to have you here. And we will be back next week for another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an
所以请确保你关注了我们。如果你愿意，请给我们一个五星好评，并将这期节目分享给需要听到它的人。如果你有节目建议，或者有相反的观点，或者想分享你的想法，请随时在Instagram上私信我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。我们非常欢迎你来到那边与我们一同分享这段旅程，你还可以看到幕后内容和视频内容。再次感谢你的收听。我想我已经说过大概三次了，但很高兴你能来这里。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment. for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中坚韧精神、体能训练和培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%节目。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看播客》节目中。对于1979年来说，那对我而言是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选
a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple
一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看播客》。
podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难之道》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方其实都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难之道》。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人的经历。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。